[Music]
now the pentagon says two high-profile
isil k members were killed in a drone
strike in eastern afghanistan the
taliban has since told reuters it should
have been they should have been informed
of the move first and that three others
were also injured now that attack
followed thursday's bomb attack at kabul
airport that was claimed by the group it
killed at least 175 people including 13
american service members
i am not going to talk about
specific capabilities isis may have lost
in this strike they lost a planner and
they lost a facilitator and they've got
one wounded
and the fact that two of these
individuals are no long longer walking
on the face of the earth that's a good
thing it's a good thing for the people
of afghanistan it's a good thing for our
troops and our forces at that airfield
and i think i'm just going to leave it
there
well the u.s is now one of the last
countries still evacuating afghan
civilians trying to flee after the
taliban takeover the uk meanwhile says
its final flight for civilians has now
left kabul that means hundreds of
afghans eligible to fly to the uk will
be left behind
now for afghans who didn't manage to
leave or who decided to stay life is
getting more challenging hundreds as you
can see gathered outside a bank in kabul
after failing to withdraw cash many
civil servants say they haven't been
paid in months
it's almost 10 days that i've been
waiting here to get my salary i am an
employee of the government we have a
patient at home we have our problems we
cannot take our salaries out a few days
ago the banks reopened but are closed
again give us our salaries so that we
can be able to solve our problems
well the taliban has yet to announce the
makeup of its caretaker government but
it has just appointed governors and
police chiefs in 33 of afghanistan's 34
provinces rob mcbride is across the
latest for us from kabul
you do get a real sense that at the
airport that finally we are getting into
the end game of what has been a very
long and often chaotic and traumatic
process this whole evacuation uh
exercise um we the surest signs of that
are coming with the taliban now taking
over a lot of the guarding duties from
the u.s military this is a process that
began
friday evening with the u.s in agreement
with the taliban withdrawing from some
of the guard posts on the outer
perimeter and withdrawing from some of
their guard duties inside the airport
and those jobs now being uh taken over
by the taliban themselves as the u.s
reduce the size of their perimeter in
preparation uh for the final withdrawal
of the final boots on the ground if you
like it is uh not meant to that people
are staying away from the airport you do
get a feeling that a lot of people by
now will have given up hope of getting
onto a flight that they will have
realized that it is fairly hopeless but
as flights are still going for others it
will probably make it even a more
desperate quest to try to get onto some
of these last remaining flights but we
do know from the noises of aircrafts
that going overhead and so on though we
are seeing fewer flights now arriving
fewer flights departing as we're getting
closer to this uh deadline for the end
of this evacuation
well rob reynolds is in washington d.c
with more on what the pentagon is saying
about those isil k targets being claimed
by the u.s military
while he described the two individuals
who were killed by this drone strike and
one
who was injured as high-profile members
of isil k
he would not commit to saying that they
were in any way behind
the planning of the deadly attack on the
kabul air base
kabul airport that killed 13 u.s
service members and
many many afghans over 170 afghans he
would not say that he would not go that
far
so we don't know at this point
officially whether these individuals
were involved in planning that or
whether they were more or less targets
of opportunity that the u.s was able to
identify through intelligence of various
types and then
unleash the drone strike against them
some other items that we we learned from
this uh uh kirby saying that uh there is
an active and dynamic threat uh at the
uh at the airport in kabul uh that uh
the u.s
forces there are aware of this and are
taking every step they can to prevent
any further attacks to prevent loss of
life he also
said that the u.s will continue well
general taylor said the u.s will
continue to control the airport right up
until the 31st of august which he
indicated was still the end date for the
operation of
removing afghans and american
citizens well glenn carl is a former
deputy national intelligence officer for
transnational threats at the cia and he
says intelligence gathering in
afghanistan can still be done but it
will now be more difficult
there are multiple kinds of intelligence
uh
that are used to
uh form
assessments it's called all source all
source intelligence collections so
you'll have satellites you'll have a
radio transmission intercepts you'll
have traffic analysis literally
studying the movement of vehicles and
people and then what we all think of you
have human sources the the advantage
that human sources have is that
they are humans are best at providing
plans and intentions of your target the
the group or individual you're seeking
to understand and learn about and that
will be harder to uh obtain now
that
access to afghanistan will be much much
much more difficult so if you can't get
access then you can't cultivate sources
or interpret people's actions but it can
still be done uh will we work more
closely with or rely on the pakistanis
if that i would not say
there has been a
troubled relationship between the united
states and pakistan for decades uh and i
i anticipate that the relations will
deteriorate
this is uh what's happened in
afghanistan is a triumph for the
pakistani intelligence service
and uh
you know the failure of our american and
western uh hopes uh so
yes the us and the uk and everybody else
will as they are able we'll work with
the pakistanis but i don't expect that
pakistanis will provide anything except
what they
think will help them which is not the
same as what we want
well meanwhile british troops have now
stopped evacuating afghans from kabul
but the head of the uk's armed forces
says hundreds of people entitled to
resettlement in the uk will be left
behind
i'm afraid it's absolutely heartbreaking
that we can't bring everybody out and i
think that point's been made very
strongly uh certainly by the defence
sector and others over the last um 10
days or so
personally i've probably had
over 100 messages from different afghans
who i know in my long association with
the country and many of those um friends
of mine won't make it out and for me you
know not a day passes within my without
me having a bit of a tear in my eye
about all of that
nadine baba is in london with the latest
on the british evacuation operation in
afghanistan
they said earlier on um via the head of
the armed forces that civilian
evacuations were ending on saturday but
now we've got it confirmed from the
ministry of defense that the last
flights purely for afghan civilians to
be evacuated out of kabul and to the uk
have actually taken off there may be
further flights
in the day which
do have a few uh afghan civilians
together with british diplomatic staff
and british military personnel so really
um this is confirmation uh that um
things have moved to a new phase that
they are continuing to both assist
people uh beyond next tuesday who want
to leave the country but also to
assist efforts in neighboring countries
to welcome refugees people fleeing
in fear for their lives into places like
iran and pakistan
the british
government say that nearly 15 000 people
have been evacuated to the uk since
mid-august but they're
in the words of nick carter the head of
the armed forces um they they've done um
the
a good job in the circumstances well
there are some criticisms that um more
than a thousand people who worked for
the british armed services are being
left behind and questions about exactly
how much assistance can be provided to
them right now
well large numbers of afghans are still
crossing into neighboring pakistan
twenty thousand people pass through the
chairman spinball that crossing on
saturday alone now only those with
pakistani residency or people needing
medical treatment are being allowed in
the u.n refugee agency has warned half a
million may flee afghanistan in the
coming months osama bin laden is at the
pakistan afghan border with this update
on pakistan's southern border with
afghanistan thousands of people in the
last 24 hours have tried to cross over
we're hearing reports that a lot of
people from the northern parts of
afghanistan because they cannot enter
pakistan from the north are moving
towards kandahar trying to cross the
spin boulder crossing and seek refuge in
pakistan or take their onward journey
from pakistan you have to bear in mind
that there is a lot of people who are
coming from provinces as far north as
trying to come towards this border
crossing and trying to enter pakistan
many of these people we're being told
are the hazaras the ethnic minority
which has come under attack various on
various occasions in afghanistan
pakistani authorities on the other hand
say they're allowing people to come in
if they have valid paperwork they can
apply for a visa and get a visa from
their functional embassy in kabul
besides that they're not going to allow
people to enter pakistan we've been
seeing desperate scenes on the border
here in the north as well where people
are pleading with with the pakistani
officials with their paperwork trying to
come and enter pakistan on humanitarian
grounds trying to seek medical help
trying to visit families because you
have to remember that on both sides of
the divide there are people who have
tribal and ethnic ties and they say that
the deteriorating security situation in
afghanistan is cause for concern and
many just want to leave
now moving on and iraq is hosting a
regional summit aimed at from